increasingly looks like putin has  massively misjudged the situation  it's clear he's misjudged the resistance  of the ukrainian people  he underestimated the strength of the  coalition his actions would  galvanize he underplayed the economic  consequences of the sanctions regime  and he overestimated the abilities of  his military to secure a rapid victory  we've seen russian soldiers  short of weapons and morale  refusing to carry out orders  sabotaging their own equipment  and even  accidentally shooting down their own  aircraft  and even though we believe putin's  advisers are afraid to tell him the  truth  what's going on  and the extent of these misjudgments  must be crystal clear to the regime